i just want to bring you some breaking
news that we're getting from reuters
this morning and we're being told that a
police officer has been
shot dead in a custody center in
south london let's talk to our home
affairs correspondent mark white what
have you got mark
yeah this incident unfolded at the main
custody
suite a new custody center for the
metropolitan police
in windmill laning croydon uh
just after 2 a.m this morning at a
quarter past two this morning
officers and paramedics treated the
officer who was shot
at the scene and he was taken to
hospital by the london ambulance service
but unfortunately he succumbed to
his injuries inside that hospital
the metropolitan police have issued a
statement saying that they are in the
process
of informing the officer's family at the
moment and they're being supported
by specialist officers now police are
also saying that a 23 year old man
was detained by officers at the scene
he's also
been taken to hospital with a gunshot
wound and remains
in a critical condition no police
firearms were discharged
during the incident so police firearms
officers were not involved in the
incident
in the first instance the the inference
being really uh
that uh the the man now being treated in
hospital
is the main suspect involved in this
incident it is a
a set of uh cells a custody suite they
have these around
london now sort of central processing
centers if you like
for those who are arrested by the police
or who are returning
on bail they go to these custody centers
just a more efficient way of working
for scotland yard it was inside we
understand
these premises that this officer was
shot now i've just had a
statement from the metropolitan police
commissioner cressida dick
she says this is a truly shocking
incident
in which one of our colleagues has lost
his life in the most tragic
circumstances
my heart goes out to his family direct
colleagues and friends
we're currently supporting his family
and also have a dedicated
team providing support to the officers
and those in the custody center
who witnessed the shooting when a
colleague dies she says
in the line of duty the shock waves and
sadness reverberate
throughout the met and our communities
policing
is a family she says within london and
nationally and we'll be
deeply uh mourning this this colleague
she goes on to say we're in the early
stages of the investigation
and are still working to establish the
circumstances
surrounding the incident and we will
provide further updates
uh when we have them and as a matter of
course
they've referred the incident to the
independent office
for police conduct who will lead an
independent investigation
the at the moment the metropolitan
police retain primacy
over this murder investigation now there
will be
as cressida dick said questions uh that
will need to be answered here
these custody suites are secure areas
uh normally anyone uh arrested as a
matter of course
and taken to a custody suite uh would be
searched
um so that is a a question
a significant question uh that uh we'll
be looking for answers to
as well the police of course uh very
quickly
uh was this individual someone who was
arrested and brought to a custody suite
was it someone perhaps who had been
previously arrested and was on bail
because they then
returned to these custody suites uh to
uh check in with the bail conditions etc
so
we don't know that at this stage but uh
certainly what we do know
absolutely tragic news coming through
from the metropolitan police at quarter
past
two this morning a police officer inside
this custody suite
in croydon shot dead by another man
a man in a hospital a 23 year old man in
a critical condition